In the last unit, we have talked about what you can do when a problem is NP-complete,
despite it being NP-complete.
And we have found out that there are techniques such as optimized search trees,
preprocessing, and fixed parameter tractability
that you can often use to solve NP-complete problems and practice
despite their hardness in general.
So what can we do when these techiniques don't work,
and we don't want to prove that P=NP?
Well, in that case, we can try something else.
We can try to give our algorithm a little leeway.
So instead of demanding that the algorithm finds the best possible solution,
we'll allow the algorithm to find a solution that is within a certain range of the best possible solution.
In return, of course, we'll demand from our algorithm that it runs in polynomial time.